bruce willis is one of hollywood's most
recognizable faces and voices it is
perhaps the cruelest blow for an actor
to confront losing that very ability to
communicate just days after his 67th
birthday though he is stepping away the
news broken by his daughter rumor on
behalf of the family including his
former wife demi moore
their statement said bruce has been
experiencing some health issues and has
recently been diagnosed with aphasia
which is impacting his cognitive
abilities as a result of this and with
much consideration bruce is stepping
away from the career that has meant so
much to him this is a challenging time
they wrote but as bruce always says live
it up and together we plan to do just
that
he has been working regularly and the
news is a shock to hollywood part of the
reason this news came as such a surprise
is because bruce willis is just 67 years
old and in fact he had five movies in
various stages of production that were
expected to come out in 2022 and three
more also in the works so he was still
very much in the prime of his career and
uh there was an expectation that we
would be seeing more from bruce willis
for years to come experts say the fact
aphasia can affect the ability to speak
and write and even understand language
is alarming for everyone nearby we hope
of course that a person will regain all
that has been lost but you never really
know
and it's generally quite sudden right as
opposed to something like dementia which
is usually kind of a gradual
lessening of abilities
aphasia because of
how it's acquired through that
neurological event
is something that's very sudden you're
usually you know fine one day and not
fine at all the next day we don't know
how long bruce willis has been suffering
from this condition but the experts say
it could have been caused by something
like a head injury or a stroke there is
treatment available speech and language
therapy but the chances of its success
depend on the extent of the damage to
his brain
that will determine whether he can ever
act again if this is the end of his
career he leaves a legacy of more than a
hundred movies but the saddest of all
ways to bow out greg milam sky news
hollywood